so we've got the equation x squared plus
y squared is equal to 1 I guess we could
call it a relationship and if we were to
graph all of the points x and y that
satisfy this relationship we get a unit
circle like this and what I'm curious
about in this video is how we can figure
out the slope of the tangent line at any
point of this unit circle and what
immediately might be jumping out in your
brain is well a circle defined this way
this isn't a function it's not Y
explicitly defined as a function of X
for any x value you actually have two
possible Y's that satisfy this
relationship right over here so you
might be tempted to maybe split this up
into two separate functions of X you
could say Y is equal to the positive
square root of 1 minus x squared and you
could say Y is equal to the negative
square root of 1 minus x squared take
the derivatives of each of these
separately and you would be able to find
the derivative for any X at or the
derivative of the slope of the tangent
line at any point but what I want to do
in this video is literally leverage the
chain rule to take the derivative
implicitly so that I don't have to
explicitly define Y is a function of X
either way and the way we do that is
literally just apply the derivative
operator to both sides of this equation
and then apply what we know about the
chain rule because we are not explicitly
defining Y as a function of X and
explicitly getting Y is equal to F prime
of X they call this which is really just
a application of the chain rule we call
it implicit differentiation implicit
differentiation and what I want you to
keep in the back of your mind the entire
time is that it's just an application of
the chain rule so let's apply the
derivative operator to both sides of
this so it's the derivative with respect
to X of x squared plus y squared x
squared plus y squared on the left hand
side of our equation and then that's
going to be equal to the derivative
with respect to X on the right hand side
I'm just doing the same exact thing to
both sides of both sides of this
equation now if I take the derivative of
the sum of two terms that's the same
thing as taking the sum of the
derivative so this is going to be the
same thing as the derivative with
respect to X of x squared plus the
derivative with respect to X of Y
squared I'm writing all my orange stuff
first so let's see this is going to be x
squared it's going to be Y squared and
then this is going to be equal to the
derivative with respect to X of a
constant this isn't changing with
respect to X so we just get zero now
this first term right over here we have
done many many many many many times the
derivative with respect to X of x
squared is just the power rule here it's
going to be two times X to the first
power or we could just say 2x now what's
interesting is what we're doing right
over here the derivative with respect to
X of Y squared and the realization here
is to just apply the chain rule if we're
taking the derivative with respect to X
of this something we just have to take
the derivative let me make it clear
we're just going to take the derivative
of our something the derivative of Y
squared that's what we're taking that
you can kind of view that as a function
with respect to Y with respect to Y and
then multiply that times the derivative
of Y the derivative of Y with respect to
X we're assuming that Y does change with
respect to X Y is not some type of a
constant that we're writing just in
abstract terms so we're taking the
derivative of this whole thing with
respect to Y once again just the chain
rule and then we're taking the
derivative of Y with respect to X you it
might be a little bit clearer if you
kind of thought of it as the derivative
with respect to X of of Y as a function
of X Y as a function of X this might be
or Y is a function of x squared which is
essentially another way of writing what
we had here this might be a little bit
clearer in
terms of the chain rule the derivative
of Y is the function of x squared with
respect to Y of X so the derivative of
something squared the derivative of
something squared with respect to that
something times the derivative of that
something with respect to X this is just
the chain rule I want to say it over and
over again this is just this is just the
chain rule so let's do that what do we
get on the right hand side over here and
I'll write it over here as well this
would be equal to the derivative of Y
squared with respect to Y is just going
to be two times y 2 times y just an
application of the chain rule and the
derivative of Y with respect to X well
we don't know what that is so we're just
going to leave that as times the
derivative of Y times the derivative of
Y with respect to X so let's just write
this down over here so what we have is
2x 2x plus 2x plus derivative of
something squared with respect to that
something is 2 times the something and
Kate in this case the something is y so
2 times y and then times the derivative
of Y the derivative of Y with respect to
X and this is all going to be equal to
all going to be equal to 0 now that was
interesting now we have an equation that
has the derivative of Y with respect to
x in it and this is what we essentially
want to solve for this is the slope of
the tangent line at any point so all we
have to do at this point is solve for
the derivative of Y with respect to X
solve this equation so let's do that and
actually just so we all so we can do
this whole thing on the same page so we
can see where we started
let me copy and paste this up here this
is where we left off and let's continue
there so let's say let's subtract 2x
from both sides so we're left with 2y
times the derivative of Y with respect
to X is equal to we're subtracting 2x
from both sides so it's equal to
negative 2x and then if we really want
to solve for the derivative of Y with
respect to X we can just divide both
sides by 2i we just divide both sides by
2y
and we are left with the derivative of Y
with respect to X I'll scroll down a
little bit the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to is equal to
well the twos cancel out we are left
with negative x negative x over over y
so this is interesting
we didn't have to explicitly define y as
a function of X here but we got our
derivative in terms of an X and a y not
just only in terms of an X but what does
this mean well if we wanted to find
let's say we wanted to find the
derivative at this point this point
right over here which if you're familiar
with the unit circle so if this was a if
this was a 45 degree angle this would be
the square root of 2 over 2 comma the
square root of 2 over 2 what is the
slope of the tangent line there well we
figured it out it's going to be the
negative it's going to be negative x
over Y so the slope of the tangent line
here the slope of the tangent line right
over here the slope is going to be equal
to negative x so negative square root of
2 over 2 over Y over square root of 2
over 2 which is equal to negative 1 and
it looks that looks just about right